Es geschah am Dienstag in dieser Gesamtschule
in Lünen, in Nordrhein-Westfalen: Ein Schüler
wurde getötet, und die Polizei hat einen
Mitschüler festgenommen.
Der tatverdächtige 15-Jährige wurde am Morgen
festgenommen, wie Staatsanwaltschaft und Polizei
in Dortmund mitteilten.
Die Ermittler gehen nach ersten Erkenntnissen
nicht von einem Amoklauf aus.
Die Sprecherin der Polizei Dortmund, Dana
Seketa, sagte:
"Das ist natürlich für alle nachvollziehbar,
ein sehr schwerwiegendes Delikt.
Wichtig ist die Polizeiarbeit, aber auch die
Betreuung der Schüler.
Viele Seelsorger waren hier.
Um eben auch die emotional Aufgewühlten zu
betreuen und hier Unterstützung zu bieten.
Der getötete Junge war 14 Jahre alt.
Eine Mordkommission übernahm die Ermittlungen.
Der Tatverdächtige sollte vernommen werden.
Laut Polizei sind Opfer und Tatverdächtiger
deutsche Staatsangehörige.
Der Tatverdächtige, der in Deutschland geboren
sei, verfüge zusätzlich auch noch über
die kasachische Staatsbürgerschaft.